I don't know about you but I love
rushing home to watch my shows before
homework and mr. Rogers neighborhood was
one of them Fred Rogers felt like the
friendliest dad or grandfather on the
block so warm and welcoming of all kinds
of people it's no surprise that millions
of people grew up knowing the phrase
won't you be my neighbor he always gave
somebody a chance to just be special on
their own without any expectations
here's everything you need to know
before you go he was just this beloved
figure who saw goodness and everybody
Fred Rogers was a major presence in
children's TV programming for more than
50 years he was inspired to create
children's content due to his own
childhood experiences he was a shy
sickly and lonely child but came out of
his shell in high school his goal was to
always encourage and nurture children to
become their best selves which led to
his first show in Canada from 1962 to
1966 and for all of you young kids out
there who have never seen an episode let
me fill you in
mr. Rogers neighborhood aired on PBS in
each half-hour segment Roger started the
show by entering his home clearly his
set and sang the song it was his ritual
to replace his jacket dress shoes he was
wearing with a zip-up cardigan and blue
sneakers in each episode he spoke
directly to the camera reaching beyond
the set to engage instinctively with his
viewers he covered a variety of topics
that most other children's television
shows shied away from these were subject
matters like anger competition divorce
and war there was always something you
can do with
and that you feel Fred Rogers gain the
love and admiration of many when he
spoke about the death of his goldfish in
a 1970 episode his empathetic approach
to tricky subjects always taught
children to lead with peace and kindness
he also had frequent and sometimes
recurring guests that had different
occupations to teach kids about the many
talents and roles that people can have
in this world when you learn something
different every day
we certainly do sometimes we're learning
we don't even know we're learning mr.
McFeely the neighborhood post office
delivery man appeared in almost every
episode his catchphrase was speedy
deliveries in addition to his wonderful
presence on TV Fred Rogers was also a
loving husband to his wife Joann of
fifty years of which he had two sons
with he was known for having a spiritual
life as well studying a variety of
faiths and culture as a Presbyterian
minister his legacy includes dozens of
books both for children and adults and
the release of a number of musical
recordings and in 2001 he was awarded
the Presidential Medal of Freedom he
also earned a Lifetime Achievement Emmy
and was inducted into the television
Hall of Fame in 2018 the documentary
won't you be my neighbor was released
and covered the life and legacy of our
dear legend mr. Fred Rogers the film is
the highest-grossing biographical
documentary of all time and won three
Critics Choice documentary awards a
Gotham award a Producers Guild of
America Award and an Independent Spirit
Award the film a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
takes us behind the set of Mister Rogers
neighborhood to tell us more about this
kind man we know and love but gives us
more insight into how he directly
affected people you love broken people
like me
sometimes we have to ask for help and
that's okay
I started looking at many many many many
hours of the half hour up mr. Rogers
neighborhood I read the scripts as
handwritten scripts of the shows but
rather than try to go with a microscopic
mole for mold imitation Fred Rogers it
was a cadence a quietness a slowness he
adorable his friend he looks wonderful
Fred Rogers was a huge fan of Tom Hanks
it's a very needful film right now he
leaves behind a legacy of peace and
compassion that serves as a teachable
wisdom for generations to come
hearing Fred's voice is really
reassuring in these times there's
something about his message that feels
more important now than ever so now you
know and now you can go see a beautiful
day in the neighborhood in theaters
November 22nd
[Music]